عشق امين كره القدم وتعلق بها منذ صغره
ومد بساط احلامه نحو تحقيق هدف لا يراه
بعيدا وهو يصبح لاعب محترفا تشير اليه
اصابع كشاف النجوم
هذا اليوم ليس كبقيه الايام بالنسبه الى
امين اذ لعب مع فريقه في الحي مباراه في
احد الدوريات المحليه
بتمنى ان شاء الله
قدام واكون لاعب نجمه ان شاء الله لاعب
كبير
لملاعب كره القدم
الشهاده السودانيه ويستعد لدخول الجامعه
لم يتوقف شغفه بكره القدم عند حدود
ممارستها فحسبه بل ان متابعه الاحداث
الرياضيه العالميه ايضا رسمت له ملامح شرف
من نوع اخر انه شغف متابعه المونديال مع
الاصدقاء باحدى دور الشباب في الحي الذي
يسكنه
عند اصحابي
احسن يعني من البيت
ترجع الكوره المنتخب الاسترالي
تتفاوت اعمارهم لكن اهتمامهم ينصب نحو عدم
تفويت فرصه المتابعه الجماعيه لمونديال
قطر فتحول المكان الى منتدا رياضيا يحلو
فيه السمر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ثقيله
تحولت هذه الساحه الى منطقه مشجعين مع
احتدام التنافسي بين منتخبات المونديال
هنا يتابعون باهتمام تفاصيل ما يجري ليكون
ولو عن بعد جزء من اهم واكبر حدث
الرياضيين في العالم
اسامه سيد احمد الجزيره من منطقه الازهري
جنوب الخرطوم